pour voir en france maintenant pour des
raisons économiques touristiques
d'attraits touristiques certains
départements français entendent bien
être rebaptisé ce fut le cas je choisis
un exemple pour les basses pyrénées
devenu pyrénées atlantiques où les
basses-alpes devenu alpes de haute
provence aujourd'hui c'est le conseil
général de saône et loire qui veut
rebaptiser son département le nom choisi
proposer la bourgogne du sud nicolas
lemarignier alexandre de kits patrimoine
paysage vignoble bienvenue en burqa ou
plutôt en saône et loire
enfin plus exactement en bourgogne du
sud bon c'est vrai c'est un peu
compliqué certains touristes étrangers
en perdent eux mêmes le sens de
l'orientation
leboncoin la bourgogne on connaît bien
et c'était une surprise de découvrir que
ça se trouve en saône et loire charles
et loire je citerai des touristes
étrangers qui viennent régulièrement
nous solliciter pour visiter les
châteaux de la loire
parce qu'il ya le vocable loire dans
notre dans le nom de notre département
il était temps de remédier à cela estime
le président du conseil général
et puis saône et loire ce n'est pas
assez vendeur pour les touristes et les
clients souvent d'un produit qui
viennent bourgogne du sud il est connu
dans le monde entier comme venant d'une
terre qui est réputé vaut faire des
produits de qualité alors qu'ils vendent
un produit de saône-et-loire personne ne
sait d'où il sort la solution c'est de
changer de nom d'adopter la dénomination
bourgogne du sud
enfin ça c'est le président qu'il dit
mais il faut convaincre le conseil
d'état et puis aussi les habitants et là
les avis sont partagés
pas un gag non je vous assure que c'est
sérieux crois pas trop
il va l'apesa bourgogne du sud
bicus vannes pour vous c'est bien comme
ça c'est bien comme ça voilà on est allé
en angleterre a pas longtemps en
vacances on parle de son nouveau
roumaine en belgique sont françoise
horny rien d'une bonbonne pas loin du
beaujolais
tout de suite ça fait tilt vous l'aviez
comme en bourgogne du sud ont difficile
la procédure de changement de
dénomination ne sera pas engagée avant
l'autre mais déjà sur les dépliants
touristiques
le nouveau nom est adopté